thanks for coming out this morning so I
want to talk for the next 17 minutes
about how to win no matter what category
you're in so and I want to start to
really by saying something that I've
noticed about great entrepreneurs and
great entrepreneurs don't start out by
actually saying I want to go start a
company they actually start out by
saying I want to solve this problem no
matter what industry they're in so I'm
the founder and CEO of this company
hints how many have had hints before I
can hardly see you out there but I
believe you
so I started hints about twelve years
ago out of my own interest to get off of
a little-known soda called Diet Coke so
I was drinking diet coke every day
religiously I think you could fairly
call me an addict to Diet Coke and I
realized that Diet Coke after
eliminating Diet Coke was doing lots of
not such great stuff to me so I was 50
pounds overweight I had for the first
time in my life developed terrible adult
acne and no energy and trying to figure
out after going to see a number of
doctors what was wrong with me and then
when I actually went and eliminated the
diet coke and started drinking plain
water I thought wow in six months fifty
pounds were gone the acne was gone the
energy was back up and it was that
simple so I'm going to talk a little bit
about you know four things that I really
see sort of in my own journey of looking
at you know what it really was and what
would allowed me to win I'm still
winning along the way but definitely as
I started to look really at what is it
that helps me to sort of do what I'm
doing today so first of all I looked at
solving problems and as I mentioned this
was the biggest problem for me and when
I started to look at the soda industry
as a whole
I really looked at diet diet coke as
well as diet pepsi and thought that you
know these are large public companies
who really out to actually get me to
drink soda they were not interested in
actually helping me get healthier as a
consumer they really wanted to continue
to sell me stuff by getting lots of
celebrities and athletes to sort of show
me that they drink those products and
therefore they're going to be that's
going to help me to get healthier and so
if I really wanted to actually have
change I couldn't rely on those guys to
actually go and develop this product for
me so I thought I'm going to actually go
and figure out how to do this product
and get it out on the market so I think
when I started to think about developing
hands I go back to what I originally
said which was I never thought I want to
go run a beverage company I want to go
start a beverage company I make college
students feel really great by telling
them I was never that person who said I
want to go found the next big energy
drink company or soda company I really
want to do something that makes a
difference and what I started to see was
that if I actually went out and started
this company that I could make a
difference not just in myself and in my
family's life but also in a lot of other
people's lives and helping them to get
healthier and so that's what I decided
to do so I think a lot about other
entrepreneurs and lots of different
industries this is probably one of my
favorite photos of Steve Jobs - the big
Idol of mine or somebody that I've
really admired over the years but I
think that something that great
entrepreneurs do is that they not only
search for why and sort of they're
developed in how they're developing
their own product and ultimately their
own company but why are their biggest
competitors potential biggest
competitors actually doing what they're
doing so somebody like Steve Jobs wasn't
actually going out to start a company he
was actually trying to create a better
computer and other entrepreneurs like
Mark Zuckerberg for example was not out
to develop a company he was actually
trying to create trying to solve a
problem around community
and there's other Sara Blakely another
one of my favorites who decided to
launch a launch a product really around
pantyhose and solving a problem so it
might not be your problem that these
great entrepreneurs are trying to solve
but they're actually trying to solve
them for themselves first and then move
on to try and solve them for other
people so talking about talking about my
own situation when I went when I was
really trying to look at solving a
problem and going back to to Steve and
sort of other people that I look at and
admire I ended up launching Hantz at
Whole Foods in San Francisco and after a
few months realized that I really didn't
have a clue about what I was actually
setting out to do so things like shelf
life things like distribution I had
grown up in the tech industry I had
launched aol's ecommerce business way
back when and developed it into a
billion-dollar business and left in 2001
and was really looking at like I thought
okay I can go and do this other industry
it's really interesting and solving a
problem for myself but after a few
months I realized oh I have no idea
what I'm doing and so a friend of mine
said hey I have this friend that is uh
that is an executive at Coke and and he
was telling a major executive at Coke
about what you guys were doing and he
said he'd be happy to chat with you so
my original intent was to really get
this guy on the phone and just
understand how do I actually create a
shelf-life in a product that is more
than you know six weeks basically that
was the initial thing that was the
initial product and so as I got him on
the phone the the conversation quickly
turned into a few different sound bites
in my head
number one he went on to tell me as I
started to describe my company and
really the product that I was that I was
looking to launch it was really around
no sweeteners and so you think about it
now it was sort of a silly conversation
for me to have with a coke exec
especially 12 years ago because he was
hearing me saying I live in San
Francisco there's lots of people like me
that don't want sweet and really want to
drink water but aspire to drink water
but they just can't get off of the
sweeteners and so he continued to talk
to me about how how I was wrong and how
you know consumers really really like
sweet and that the key thing was to get
consumers to believe that it's not
really about sweet but it's it's really
about zero calories and I you know for a
minute thought well I think you know
he's wrong but instead I just let him
talk and I left the competition continue
to talk for a while and then I realized
that he was really believing all of his
and and basically I was so
fortunate to be able to have this
conversation with them and so I also
realized that he was headed down one
river and I was headed down the other
river and that he had a lot more money
than me and so I should just keep going
down my river and paddle as fast as I
can
well he's got his big ship with lots of
dollars going down that river and this
leads me to point number three that
these large companies and companies like
you know the big soda companies that I
go up against once they actually start
to realize that you're a real threat and
that you actually may have been right
they'll be your biggest naysayers out
there bill they'll do everything to
basically try and undo everything that
you're trying to do so everything from
walking into you know large stores like
Target or Walmart and throwing your
product out in the garbage things like
that that are you know really annoying
but I think at the end of the day what
they can't do is actually undo the
problem that you're trying to solve and
what I also realize is that the ship
metaphor really goes along with these
large companies because if they see that
you're focused and actually trying to
solve a problem for the consumer that
it's very hard to turn that ship and
especially if they're focused on
something that is not actually solving a
why and solving a problem but instead
just believing their own stuff and again
you see this over and over again in
every single industry where you have
great ideas great problems great problem
solvers and the large companies when
it's too late aren't having to try and
figure out how do I turn the ship around
so large companies you know such as
Xerox and Kodak and lots of them that
have been in my lifetime that have
really tried to turn the ship around and
have you know really had a tough time
doing it and it's just been too late so
I think that the key thing sorry to have
to grab a grab some hands as I'm going
along so other key lessons probably the
fourth big lesson that I've learned the
hard way is passion Trump's experience
so I heard over and over again you came
from the tech industry you're you know
this little chicky out in San Francisco
was during your thing out there and you
know tech tech ignorant tech you know
obnoxiousness whatever you know the
saying was that that they came up with
in the beverage industry so I started to
believe it and I thought if I can just
actually hire those people from the
large soda companies then I'll actually
be able to you know start my big company
and really get the right distribution
and really solve all of my problems and
so my worst problem was actually hiring
people that had gone so far down a path
with one of these large companies
because I spent more time undoing the
way that they had been taught to think
my best employees today are the ones who
have been who have been passionate about
a problem and have really identified
that it is a problem
so sugar and sweetener
earth are the problem and if they in and
people that really want to go up against
these large companies are the ones that
I found to be the best people in your
company and often the people that really
save you a lot of time because you bring
these people in who thinks differently
about things you can teach them in our
industry how to sell beverages not that
hard not that complicated it's really
about just thinking differently and
again going back to many of the other
great entrepreneurs I think that they
would say exactly the same thing that
you want to hire people that are really
thinking differently about things and
are most passionate about about the
problem and how you do it so I think
it's just in closing I just I look at
you know in building this company and
sort of the position that I was in as an
entrepreneur and and again going back to
to kind of the why so often I talked to
entrepreneurs and I asked them why did
you actually go and start this company
and if the reason is that they wanted to
get out of working for the man or you
know or not really being that excited
about being inside of a large company
then entrepreneur ISM might not be for
you because it's a really hard thing
right many of you are entrepreneurs out
there and have started your companies it
takes a lot of time it takes a lot of
energy it takes a lot of chutzpah you
have to conquer you know lots of things
you have to raise lots of money in many
cases so I think it's really it's just
really a it's a tough road to go down
but also if you can turn around in a few
years from now and say that not that me
and my team actually solve that problem
and that there wouldn't be this company
this there wouldn't be this category
there wouldn't be this industry then I
think that that's such a valuable thing
to be able to say that you were a part
of so thanks so much
[Applause]